The joe rogan experience here reminded me of when you talked about grabbing them
in the laundry basket.
Do you remember back in Boston?
You were out one night with Jennifer and I was home and I swear to God on my
father's grave,
this happened.
I rented Batman,
the blockbuster.
Uh,
and I put it in and I'm sitting at home and I'm watching it.
And then,
uh,
all of a sudden I see this shadow and then I turned my head and I see another
shadow and I look up and there's a bat flying around the apartment.
And I'm like,
what?
And I,
I'm scared shitless of bats.
Like,
it's like my thing.
And it's like ever since I was a kid,
my aunt had this barn near her and they had bats and they would be telling me
they were fruit bats.
And if they bite you,
you'll get rabies and you'll die.
And,
and so,
and we would always be outside playing tag at night and I would fucking,
bats would fly by and I'd freak out.
And,
and so I'm alone in the apartment and as a bat flying around and Batman is on
TV.
And so,
uh,
all I knew is they go in your hair,
which I think is like not even true.
So I put on a baseball cap backwards and I had on sunglasses and a tennis
racket.
I'm glad I didn't want to go into my eyes.
He's going to go for,
so I'm running around the apartment swinging at him and he's taken off.
He's like,
you know,
he's just,
they're erratic,
the way they fly.
You don't know where they're fucking going.
And this goes on for like 10 minutes and then there's like a standoff and I'm
waiting.
And then I hear you coming up the stairs and you came in and you open the door
and you go,
what the fuck are you doing?
And I get this a bad in here.
And you just,
you just grab the tennis racket out of my hand.
And he walked up and he was in the window and you just bashed him once and he
just went down.
And then you just walked over and you had taken your hand and you just went into
the kitchen and start eating it.
I'm standing there with sunglasses and I,
Ana,
I remember that.
That's hilarious.
You have to gauge at any given,
in any given interaction with the audience,
you gauge who that you got to fucking figure it out fast.
Are they gonna,
are they gonna charge the stage?
Are they going to keep heckling or are they going to leave you?
Gotta you gotta tear it out.
Ditches and Boston's,
you got physically attacked.
You got an a wrestling match with wrestling match.
No,
the guy came up,
he,
uh,
took a swing at me.
I ducked,
I hit him in the head with a microphone.
And then he was from the Israeli army.
He was a cab driver who was there.
His name was Simcoe.
I still remember that because I said,
you know,
that's the name of the village,
idiot and Woody Allen's movie,
love and death.
Right?
And so he came up and he got me in a fucking headlock and that dude was spinning
me around the stage and knocking down tables.
I couldn't get out and about,
you know,
stitches.
It's,
it's the stage is surrounded by the crowds.
So of course everybody stands out cause they want to see the fight and the
bouncers can't get up there.
And so it just fucking went on for a while.
And then finally the bouncers came up and two of my buddies,
you know,
Mike Gibbons,
Mike,
and uh,
were at the bar and they're trying to get up there.
They can't get out there.
And,
uh,
the got 'em out and then the owner,
you remember that guy?
I'm hairy little dude,
Harry.
He goes,
uh,
yeah,
how you can afford it.
He goes,
uh,
okay.
Yeah,
Fits you.
Gotta you got 10 minutes left.
And they reintroduced me.
I'm like,
what?
I think you got fucking done.
So I go up and I get on stage and I got a standing ovation because they would,
they rather it's Boston.
I read a see a fight than his comedy show.
My first standing ovation of my life.
And then I went to the chiropractor.
My neck was fucked.
Do you remember what you said to the audience?
Yeah.
I walked up and uh,
and they clapped and once they calm down,
I looked around and I go,
all right,
who's next?
Yeah,
I remember that.
I wasn't there for it.
I remember you telling me that and everybody else was talking about how you said
that too.
And I was like,
that's hilarious.
See,
Brian Frazier gave me the line.
He was,
he was the audience.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
Interesting though.
It's weird how fame,
you can't predict who's going to last with fame.
Um,
you know,
like of the Charlie's angels,
you didn't know Farah was going to,
I guess you Kinda knew fire was going to be the one you thought the other ones
would be pretty big too.
Yeah.
Jacqueline Smith.
I mean,
all she did was hair shampoo commercials for the rest of her life.
She was always,
fuck.
Hod Is,
fuck my kid is watching Charlie's angels reruns right now.
I watched one yesterday.
Try pulling yourself away.
Oh,
I could stare at those chicks all fucking day.
Well,
it's also weird that you're,
you,
it's Kinda like when you watch a show like that,
it's not just that,
oh,
you know,
Jaclyn smiths pretty,
but it's also like,
this is a time capsule.
Like this is,
they've captured this stuff that went on in the 1970s and you'll watch it again.
All right.
That's weird,
man.
That's a weird outfit.
Somebody talking about the bootleg jeans,
they were wearing these seven date encapsulated seventies fashion.
Yeah,
no shit man.
You know,
like a denim denim vests in the feathered hair
and they probably fall in a big part.
We're one of the reasons why I became so popular.
Right.
Why the fashion did,
I'm sure on those shows,
I'm sure.
Like I guarantee the dukes of Hazzard probably influenced a lot of idiots to
wear cowboy boots.
Daisy Dukes,
definitely JV
launch.
That dude.
How she might've been the hottest chick ever on TV.
And I see.
All right.
Who Chrissy from?
From fucking three's company.
Daisy Duke.
No.
How dare you take Chrissy because you're broken.
You're incisor rotten.
You have to go to a doctor telling you,
go to a doctor.
Chris,
he's hot,
but she's not as hot as daisy dukes.
You know it's pretty hot even though she's,
she's also,
but she's older so you can't compare that.
You go for an old pick of Catherine Bach.
You fuck,
I know what you're gonna do.
But I'm the chick from modern family,
the Latino on it,
dude,
I'll take it.
Yeah,
she's only 40 I mean,
but she looks like she's 30 and her tits still look like I don't,
you can't fake it.
They have,
there is some of that cleavage.
You can push it up,
but she doesn't push it up where it's straining.
It's a little bit of bounce,
it'll jiggle,
but yet there's the,
there's Pie.
Their pie shaped.
They're perfectly round.
She's stupid Hock Tan and that accent puts it right over the top.
She's stupid hot end.
There's this element of knowing that this is not going to last like what you are
as you're looking at a flower that's been cut and you're putting it in the vase
and there's just like something even extra beautiful about the fact that it's
not even attached to the root anymore.
And you've got a day to look at it like this.
This is it.
Now,
tomorrow's going to be wilted the day after that you're gonna want to throw it
out,
but right now it's the hunter Thomas of hot.
Yeah.
Thompson.
What did I say?
Thomas?
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
You know both of them are hot.
Yeah,
but daisy dukes dirtier
Chris.
He's bending over like fuck me in the ass hole.
I'll tell you what,
like who's done a better job of keeping it together?
Well,
both of them.
Both of them failed.
Oh No,
she did the exercise videos tight for a little bit,
but still doing it.
Shampoo commercials.
That's not Jaclyn Smith though.
That's daisy Duke.
That's Catherine Bach.
Nobody worked at though.
Nipples were permanently erect on that show.
They probably iced him up before every scene.
I bet they did,
but they,
because guys would get like pumped up.
You guys do like pushups and stop before scenes to pump up their muscles.
Yeah.
I guarantee they do that.
They went for it.
Yeah.
That was everything and that was what you were selling.
If you're selling,
if you're selling cars,
when you leave them dirty or where'd you Polish them?
He got to polish the car.
You've got to polish the car.
He's selling cars,
you're selling tickets.
What are you doing?
Get that ice cube out,
honey.
The headlights watching it for the story.
Nobody's watching it for the story.
That's so when she died,
man,
that was one of those things where it's like,
wow,
Farrah Fawcett dead.
That was just hard to wrap my head around because when I was a kid,
she was it.
Who Was it?
Everybody had a fair Fawcett poster on their wall.
Every girl did and it was at one poster of her like smiling and she had the
feathered hair and everything like that and like she influenced a whole
generation of where that hair,
it's gotta be the quintessential poster in,
in America of all time.
Probably famous posters ever.
Yeah,
that's it right there.
Look at her real and the nipple.
You can't see,
that's not high def,
so you can't see the nipple.
But the nipple is very proudly displayed.
And this semester.
Yeah.
Many of the photos of the nipple Rockton she was so pretty.
She was like one of the first television bombshell types,
right?
Uh,
yeah.
I mean,
I take it back.
My fear was wonder woman,
old wonder woman.
Oh,
Linda Carter.
Lynda Carter's tough to look at it now.
Yeah.
Not that she looks at Lynda Carter was saying,
oh,
look at that and nibble.
Yeah.
Linda Carter.
I mean,
she doesn't look terrible,
but she's an older woman now.
It's just when you remember how beautiful she was when she was wonder woman,
I have wished they would die.
I don't want to sit.
It ruins it.
You know what's fucked though,
man?
Like it's weird when you go back and watch like Batman or any of those,
uh,
old school like superheroes,
no one worked out.
No one worked out like halfway bought a belly.
You look at Catherine Bach there.
She didn't work out.
Look at her legs.
Felt like all mushy and shit.
Right?
Everybody was all mushy and sloppy.
They were good for a couple of decades.
John Wayne.
Oh,
beer belly and shit with little skinny arms.
That skill gap under the legs,
the size of her thighs.
Dude,
her fucking body.
That is it.
She was an athlete.
She was in an Olympic athlete,
I believe.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
it's hot.
Let's all agree.
She's the hottest shit.
Yeah,
I think she is in the was the hottest.
Oh wait.
[inaudible] a major contender.
Who?
Barbara Eden.
I dream of Jeannie.
She wins.
And she subservient shell too.
He was beautiful.
Yeah.
There was a comic on long island that fucked her.
Late in life though,
right?
They didn't lie,
but he can say he did it.
She was still hot.
It doesn't matter how old she was,
but she would like,
you know,
fucking find a guy,
pick them out and go,
come on,
let's do this.
Yeah.
Well she knew she could.
You know,
she was Goddamn Barbara Eden.
I know somebody who has such a late in life,
I should say,
allegedly.
Well,
this,
I know somebody who allegedly had,
no,
I know.
And we definitely had sex.
How late?
Late in life.
Real hospital bed like
actually have say winter woman.
I don't think I like,
that's a horrible pose.
Yeah,
that's fine.
It's fine.
Another one cause wonder woman.
You could find a bad one too.
I'm sure you found a good one.
Uh,
you know,
also helping me on,
but she wasn't like a few years before she died.
Whoa.
Uh,
who was not s bombshell hot but stole my heart.
Was Valerie Bertinelli one day to talk to you anymore?
Yeah.
You become a different person to me.
Shit.
You know,
I don't trust your judgment.
I mean,
cause you did a moment ago now,
now I'm like,
Greg's drunk something.
Halan.
How bad could you be there?
I knew about a back fight.
It's like Yale.
Yale's no wonder woman didn't even work out,
man.
They didn't work out back then.
It's gotta be a better picture of her.
The wonder woman.
I'm sure it had a little bit of,
I don't mind a little bit of body fat.
I think it's hot.
I like women to have like little softness to them.
I love Kim Kardashians.
I mean I don't like her person or soul,
but I love that body.
Her body is fantastic.
Well then the her ass is fat or real or was real fat.
Whatever it is.
It's ridiculous.
Like if you don't get excited about that,
you Dick,
stop working right now.
You're,
you're a,
you're a closeted homosexual.
If that's not working for you,
it's just sad.
Yes.
Dick doesn't want full pleasure dicks like,
no,
I'm just wanting to,
skinny girl cuts me with her hips.
Like a guy who buys a Prius when he wants a Mustang,
a Mustang or get this challenger now,
hey,
if I'm going to do it,
it's going to be the Mustang because I had a fetish for mustangs as a kid.
I still do.
I think I need the fact that it's the 40th anniversary is Kinda 50th
anniversary.
That's pretty cool.
Well the new one's going to have independent rear suspension,
which is going to make a big difference in the way it handles the new 2015 yeah,
there'll be out pretty soon.
I think they're out in the fall,
which is basically right here.
God.
She was so hot.
Well,
oh,
she was so hot as ridiculous.
Yeah.
Linda Carter might've been the hottest women of all time.
She might when she might win.
Yeah.
Bitch was hot.
Oh,
wait a minute.
What's that look is that she went from modern family.
Oh God.
She wins.
Everybody wins.
There's women that are listening to this right now.
Look,
fuck you.
Yeah.
Well,
let's talk about,
we talked about Jim Morrison being hot.
We talked about Joey Lawrence being hot.
Yeah,
he was beautiful.
We did a lot for the ladies on that shelf.
So since we don't feel it,
you know,
we assume that he's hot.
You know?
I mean,
I see how you would be a truck.
No,
no,
I totally felt your energy when he came on.
So I understood that he was hot zone,
the
doom,
doom about Janet Jackson.
Early nineties no,
like playboy cover,
black and white.
It's never into that.
I always found it to be so like needy racial,
I need a race.
Pick a race.
Well,
I just,
when someone is like a pop superstar,
there's forcing them down your throat.
They never seem sexy to me.
It always seem like,
oh,
here's this crazy person.
Right?
What's her name?
Um,
uh,
Miley Cyrus.
It's like,
oh,
they want you to think she's hot now.
But you know,
was Britney Spears was a child star and they forced her eye and she was fucking
hot.
But she was hot in a way that like,
like if I saw a bunch of peacocks and there was a female peacock that was an
exceptional specimen,
I was like,
wow,
that's a beautiful peacock is like that.
It's like to me hot I yes.
Physically,
yeah.
Undeniable shape and all that very beautiful button right now.
And nothing's pulling me towards that.
Everything's pushing me away from that.
Yeah.
Bet She's madness.
It's craziness.
Like that has to be part of the picture.
It has to be who's the person?
Like can you interact with a person?
It can't just be the way they look,
the way they look as great.
I mean,
it's important.
It's something,
it gives you a charge.
But if you know that their personality is all out of whack,
like you're like,
ah,
this is too,
but I want them a little out of whack.
The thing that attracted me as a,
as an insecure guy when I was single was a woman I got,
I saw the end,
I saw the dad dad left or you know,
she's got,
she's got like a uni brow.
You find,
I would find that one thing and I'd be like,
I got a shot.
That would make me so much more attracted if a girl was perfect,
I felt nothing and it wasn't even that I didn't think I could get her.
It just made me feel like I work well.
Also.
Like somebody who's a little fucked up,
they're going to,
you're going to fucking connect with them.
There's going to be a charge between you cause you both need something bad to
complete yourself.
That's a good point.
Yeah.
I definitely felt that way.
Like girls had to have really good relationships with their family.
Like man,
I know girls like,
you know,
they want you to go hang out with their parents.
Like,
Oh yeah.
Not really now,
especially if you couldn't relate.
I want a girl who needs help finding her father that Nicki Minaj,
Disney video.
Do you see that's the one that fucking Jamie keeps going on and on about and
then stop talking about it.
It's so much.
But yeah,
like there's parts where she's fingering herself in a video when a good kid,
I love that my kids see this shit.
It's just,
whoa.
Her ass is ridiculous.
They're all ass.
Everybody's got an ass.
If you look at,
if you look at Miley Cyrus,
his Twitter Avatar,
she's,
she put her own version of her album cover on it and it looks like she has a
great ass too,
but that's an illusion.
They're Photoshop the shit out of that girl weighs 18 pounds still.
Stick figure.
Yeah.
She's a very boy.
Like with her body.
Like when that thing came out in the video music awards and she danced around
and rubbed up against that guy.
You could see like she's very like guy like or skinny.
She's like skinny girl.
Like Nicki Minaj.
A slick.
It's not supple.
Yes,
that girls just a fuck house.
You look at her and you're like,
whoa.
But,
but I mean there's comics that go up and they're likable,
number one before they're funny so they can't bomb.
Which is the saddest thing in the world because the audience doesn't even get
that.
They're not even that funny cause they're likable first.
You're not likable
if you do well.
It's just cause you're funny.
I can't argue.
I can argue with what you're saying.
I always said that if I didn't know me,
I would swear I was a douchebag.
If I didn't know me,
if I just knew someone who had my characteristics and my jobs,
I left fucking most loathsome human in the world.
I got a whiny voice.
I'm fucking,
I think I'm better than people.
Oh you think you're smarter than me?
I'm like,
I really don't.
I think I'm a fucking idiot.
But I seem to have that air about me.
But it's part of what's funny though.
You'd know you're a real comic.
Like if you and I are talking and if we just happen to be on an airplane
together and some really dark shit was going on,
right,
we could start cracking each other up.
Right.
It doesn't mean we mean it,
but you're going for the laugh.
You're like one of the first guys to go for the fucked up laugh.
Like in the personal conversation.
Like you're just sitting there hanging out,
eating lunch,
and then you just,
you'll go for this.
But you don't mean that you're a really nice guy.
Right.
I don't think people who aren't either immersed in the world of standup comedy
or know a lot of standup comics,
I don't think they appreciate that.
Right.
Yeah.
I think that to me it's about,
it's a gear.
You're commenting on normal conversation.
You're,
you're,
you're making fun of what a racist would say it.
And he gets,
you know,
and you're being racist to,
right.
Also being racist was we are racist.
Are we,
this is what we are.
Okay.
We are judgmental.
It's part of evolution,
which we're constantly assessing our or environment.
And sometimes we know there's shit you're not supposed to say.
So we say it because it's funny and it's also funny because there's some truth
to it,
right?
And it's fucked up,
but there's some truth to it.
And God,
I wish it was wasn't true.
I wish stereotypes weren't true.
Right?
We should talions I wished my own relatives were an apes.
I really wished they weren't savage,
untrustworthy apes.
But they are.
That's what they have to watch.
Fucking real housewives of New Jersey.
And we've seen this in the Red Italian.
What are you seeing?
My people,
my people are savages.
I wish that wasn't true,
but it's fucking true.
Yeah,
it's hard to,
it's hard to fight against the Italian stereotype because here's the problem
with Italians,
that there's many,
is that you're enamored with the fact that you're Italian,
so you won't evolve.
Like every Italian guy,
you could meet some guy from fucking the a prairie,
prairie land Midwest,
and if he's Italian,
he'll go and get the
pause to fuzzy because they've watched the godfather.
Yeah,
they've watched sopranos and they want to sound like that and because they want
to be Italian,
whereas we're supposed to be all growing away from,
like you're saying,
the barbaric versions of ourselves should be in the past,
not perpetuated for generations.
I have friends that are back east friends.
I love him to death and I don't mind when they put it on.
I don't mind when they do the Italian talk,
a little piece of me dies.
Right,
right,
right.
I'm Irish.
Hey,
hey,
your mom is still making a good goose
epi.
Some.
They'll call me Giuseppe.
That's a big one.
Hey Giuseppe.
Very rare that that my Jewish friends call me Giuseppe if it might be already
when he was high,
but I've never seen an Italian guy have a solo fight.
It's always a fucking group jumps in.
Well,
there's a herd mentality involved and being proud of what patch of dirt you're
on.
Right.
That doesn't lend itself to courage.
Yes.
That's not the,
that's not the right mentality.
The,
the rugged individual that takes on the group and wins.
No,
that's a
so there's fucking Bob.
You believe what this guy saying?
I was Bobby.
Bobby's already Bobby's wearing a wire the entire time.
Bob In the backseat of the patrol car.
I just waited.
Testify.
What the fuck Bobby with family.
Hey look,
this fucking shit go between us.
I was wondering why we call you the rat Bobby.
And he was with Bobby to rat that fucking cock sucker knew he used to sit on my
mama's stable leak.
Gaga Gulu shy.
Think about it.
What is,
who's the number one most famous gangsters of all time?
They're all Italian guys.
They all braggadocious Gotti types or Al Capone.
I've got Paul,
Jimmy Hoffa.
Ah,
savages.
My people were criminal savages.
They make awesome food and know how to fuck.
That's it.
Girls.
Oh my God.
And your good luck.
Hot Italian girl.
The hottest who can make really good food and likes to fuck all the time.
She might beat you to death in your sleep.
Right?
And you don't mind.
It's worth it.
That's fucking crazy.
The crate.
I love Italian.
I grew up around dark,
dark Italian check.
I gave up on him last time.
Trigger Dude took a swing at me.
Rarely.
Yeah,
back in the back of the Boston days.
Right.
That's it.
I'm good at.
I'm good.
Can't date anybody like me fucking animals.
Well that's it too.
You're not supposed to date within your own race.
That's proven.
I married,
well,
actually she's half Irish,
half Jewish,
but you got to,
you got to get a little way from mom.
It's a,
well,
the Irish were the most racist of all people because we're the fairest skin.
We look down on everybody.
I don't think so.
Oh fuck man.
Really think we came to America at the time of the Italians came at basically
the same time.
So when you go to the Bronx or Boston,
they're so sweet.
They fucking hate each other and they hate everybody else because we were the
last ones to come over.
So everybody hated us.
We were the last ones to get jobs.
So we have to,
like,
the Irish were the last to the first,
the first immigrants,
English to Dutch,
Dutch,
English,
English.
The,
um,
uh,
you Scandinavians,
I know so little about the immigration of different cultures in this country.
Always know about my own family.
It was the great depression.
My grandparents came over during the depression.
This is a great book about Cornelius Vanderbilt and it kind of tracks New York
in the 18 hundreds.
And as the waves of people came over and,
uh,
it's really a won the Pulitzer prize called the first tycoon.
My Grandmother,
the last tycoon,
my grandmother grew up in the depression.
She was kind of insane because of it.
And she's still like hide things all around the house.
Like she hide money in various spots in the house.
They didn't find it until after she died.
They would shit,
oh shit.
Thousands of dollars talk to any walls.
But it's just,
but the idea was not just that she had money.
I mean she,
they were very poor,
but that she had money that she had squirreled away in to these weird spots all
over their house.
Right.
It was really weird.
I did you almost not find it before you,
well,
I didn't have anything to do with it.
His,
his children did the,
uh,
the,
my,
when my grandfather died,
I was over here and I think that's when they,
uh,
they started searching the house.
The people that were living in New Jersey,
they had it,
they had some idea that she was like,
Shit.
No,
they didn't know him.
She,
she had this,
she had had an aneurysm and she was sick for a long time because of it.
And,
um,
during that time,
my grandfather took care of her and my grandfather took care of her.
That's when I was staying with him.
And it was a very fascinating time in my life because,
um,
I had left Boston and I moved to New York,
but I couldn't really afford to live in New York.
I didn't know I had hardly any money.
So stated my grandfather,
who was living on North Ninth Street,
which was a really bad neighborhood in Newark,
the next door neighbor,
they got a battering ram broke down his fucking door because you selling crack.
And he had like an Audi like next door,
like this is fucking Newark,
New Jersey.
It's a shitty spot.
Oh Shit.
And my grandfather was taking care of my grandmother and it was just me and my
grandfather and my grandmother.
It was like one of the lowest points in my life.
I had just broken up with my girlfriend.
I had just torn my ACL and I knew that I needed surgery.
I just moved to New York.
I was completely,
totally broke and I was,
you know,
taking this big risk,
moving to New York.
I'd signed with Sussman and I want you,
I remember that.
It's trying to get my shit together.
And my grandmother like Moans,
like she's,
she's hurt so bad she can't move.
She had an aneurism 12 years ago,
so she's just lying in bed like,
yeah.
Hello
from the aneurysm on.
She was in pain all the time.
She's done is,
she's done from the aneurysm on.
They gave her 72 hours to live.
She lived for 12 years.
Yeah.
And it wasn't a good 12 years.
It wasn't a good 12 years.
See your grandfather was getting zero action.
Ah,
I'd probably do whatever you want.
Okay.
Hey,
hey is exactly what I was saying earlier.
Obama rolling over,
put the fucking Google shopping.
GRANDPA's coming in.
You get hot.
You could hide the fucking canola is,
but you're not hiding that fucking Beluga
got a big hairy guy who shares that fucking God goes,
you could say,
oh,
she got a big fucking juicy guy who saying at the end of it,
you mark it on at the end.
That's when you know you're done.
When you hit the Gaga.
Good.
On this broad,
what I fucking do you share inside of her?
My brother,
I don't know if she's moaning cousin he aneurism,
but cause I'm hitting the Gago dish.
Yeah.